[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous présente citizenken
donc un gros morceau lisseur du cinéma
donc un film de 1941 écrit produit jouer
réalisé par Orson Welles qui à l'époque
avec moins de 30 ans c'est son premier
film et c'est considéré encore sévère
comme un des meilleurs films d'histoire
du cinéma et pendant 50 ans étaient
numéro 1 au classement du magazine
britannique Sand qui chaque année sur un
panel de critiques et disait leur
meilleur film et pendant 50 ans Steen
est resté numéro 1 un film aussi culte
et légendaire que Orson Welles qui
jouent donc ce personnage de Charles
Foster Cain basé même si tu n'as jamais
été avoué officiellement mais basé plus
ou moins entre autres sur Earth qui
était à l'époque un Mania des médias et
de l'entrepreneuriat aux États-Unis le
film s'ouvre sur la mort de ce
personnage il laisse échapper un simple
mot et de ce mot en suit l'enquête d'un
journaliste qui va essayer de retracer
la vie de ce personnage qui était Kane
par témoignage entrecoupé flashback etc
c'est le premier film qui vient
une méthode de narration
on ne peut pas faire convention
narrateur on ne sait pas si le narrateur
du film dit la vérité ou pas et le
spectateur doit se construire sa vérité
par rapport aux différents témoignages
que le film nous présente ça pour
l'époque au cinéma c'était complètement
c'était jamais vu aucun film n'avait
raconté son histoire de façon aussi
décousue et transformer on s'était pas
linéaire c'était voilà donc sur
l'écriture novateur citizencan a
bousculé les codes de l'image et du
visuel parce que les temps sont premier
film hors-sol n'était pas limité par des
codes ou des conventions qui auraient pu
apprendre toute sa vie en ayant fait
déjà du cinéma depuis 15 ans il était
tellement nouveau entre guillemets à
cela il raconte que la le premier jour
où il a mis les pieds sur le plateau de
cycan et son premier jour en tant que
créateur de cinéma il a évidemment fait
du théâtre avant de la radio et beaucoup
de choses mais mais c'est ton premier
cinéma et accompagné du du très grand
chef d'opérateur grec Hollande ils ont
créé tout ce nouveau langage visuel avec
la profondeur de champ extrême en partie
inspiré de l'expression allemand des
années 20 notamment du caducteur Calgary
mais voilà c'est une canard non
seulement révolutionné les codes de la
narration l'école visuelle et devenu le
film de les gens qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
[Musique]